hi this is Kohei Nishiyama found out
crucial com Base Japan and the question
was should see you have nething like a
doctor or lawyer the answer is yes but
you know seal could be different in
their styles so I would say yes but like
I would advise CEO to to know more about
their end users and if they know their
what their end users are doing expecting
their their their expectations to
company and CEO then the code of conduct
should be really really a easy to
understand for each CEOs and then that
feeling should be the ethical basis for
the CEO so my answer to the question
should see you have an epic composure
the answer is yes just by knowing their
users they can meet expectations